[Müzik]
Bugün size
koşturmakla değil de
durmakla ilgili hayatımda geçen 3 tane
hikaye anlatacağım
liseyi 5 üzerinden neredeyse 3 ile falan
mezun oldum az kalsın kalıyordum
sonra
şöyle bir şey oldu dedik ki arkadaşlarla
birkaç tane arkadaşım vardı
Hadi bir üniversitede bir bölüme girelim
Hadi çalışalım Çünkü o kadar lisede
çalışmamışım ki yani hani çoğu konuyu
bilmiyorum ÖSS de 180 soru var Ben bir
deneme sınavı çözüyorum deneme sınavında
180'de 90 tane yapabiliyorum buyum kadar
kitap aldım
başladık çalışmaya çalıştıkça bu 90 tane
olan çözebildiğim net yüze çıktı
10010-120-130 140 beni dershanede 3
sınıftan ikinci ikinciden de biri
aldılar ondan sonra
şöyle bir şey oldu Ben çalışıyorum ama
daha fazla artmadı netler şeyi de kaldı
yani 140'da kaldı
düşünüyorum neden benim daha fazla
artmıyor dikkatsizliklerimi nasıl şey
yaparım diye evde hürriyetin şey yaptığı
kuponla verdiği bir tane ansikledi var
Ana bir tanega onun içinde böyle
bakarken şöyle bir şey fark ettim
insanın dikkati yaklaşık böyle 40-50
dakika içinde zayıflıyormuş Bunu fark
ettim ondan sonra
şöyle bir şey uydurdum kendi kendime ben
acaba durup
dinlenirsem sınav içerisinde bu deneme
sınavı çözerken
Acaba bir faydası olur mu hemencecik ilk
deneme sınavında Gözlerimi kapatıp
böyle nefesimi rahatlatıp gözlerimde
böyle bir yorgunluğu bir bulut gibi
düşünüp ağzımdan
üfleyip o bulutu 5 dakika mola vere vere
Her 45 dakikada bir deneme sınavını o
şekilde bitirdim ve 140 çıkmıştım ya
hatırlıyor musunuz denemenin sınavının
sonucu bir geldi 120
ben durup Dinlenince sınavın Sonuçta
Maalesef öyle oldu
arkadaşlarım hemencecik dalga geçtiler
Ondan sonra Dershanede beni üçüncü
sınıftan 2 sınıfa geri aldılar annem
babam Ne oldu oğlum iyi misin falan
filan dedi Neyse ama ben içimde
çok rahattım şunun bilincindeydim Ara
verince Mola verince şöyle oldu
sınavın sorularına yetiştiremedim yani o
yüzden öyle oldu Ben de dedim ki Mola
vermeyi bırakma Erhan şey yap
nasıl söyleyeyim size Mola vermeyi
bırakma ama soru çözme hızını arttır
Neyse soru çözme hızını şöyle arttırmaya
başladım
120'den 130'a çıktı 130'dan 140'a çizdi
çalışıyorum soru çözme hızını
arttırıyorum ama molaları yani deneme
sınavı içerisindeki molaları
bırakmıyorum olaya devam gözümü kapatıp
dinlendiriyorum Neyse
140-150
160 160'a kadar çıktı böyle heyecanla
gerçek sınava gireceğim bir gün var
Gerçek sınava girmeme
bir haber geldi
hop
sınavı iptal oldu
sorular çalınmış çoğu arkadaşım dedi ki
Ne yapacağız ne edeceğiz ben tabii
gerildim iyice
dedim ki biz tatile gidelim ya biz
tekrar çalışacağımıza tatile gidelim 3
hafta sonra gelir sınava gireriz Biz
Hakikaten de kampa gittik kafayı
dinledik millet çalıştı falan Ondan
sonra ben gerçek sınava girdim gerçek
sınavda tık tık tık tık tık tık soruları
çözüyorum 45 dakika sonra durdum gözleri
kapadım bulutları üfleyeceğim buramda
bir el gözü bir açtım bizim matematik
hocası bizim sınıfa düşmüş oğlum dedi ne
yapıyorsun uyuyor musun dedim uyumuyorum
bulutları üflüyorum oğlum dedi bulutları
üflemenin sırası mı Ne yapıyorsun
dakikaların saniyelerin önemli olduğu
bir yerde sen niye duruyorsun dedi dedim
bırakın şey yapmayın ben devam edeceğim
biliyorum ne yaptığını ben o şekilde
gözümü kapata dinlene bilmem ne şeklinde
O sınavı bitirdim ve O sınavda
arkadaşlar 180 soruda 170 tane doğru
yaptım
ve
neredeyse sonuncu mezun olduğum
sonuncu mezun olduğum Fethiye Lisesi'nde
hem Fethiye'de hem Muğla'da sayısalda
sözelde il birincisi oldum arkadaşlar o
kadar kötü bir puan ara rağmen
o gün Ben şunu fark ettim insan
hızlanırken
durması onu yavaşlatmıyor sonra
hayatımızda başka yerlerde de gördüm
Mesela şurada gördüm hani şu spor var ya
saniyelerle yarışıldığı aslında İnsanlar
burada da mesela duruyorlar ve burada
durmayı en iyi yapan takım kazanıyor
durmayan takım kazanamıyor illa bu
durmayı yapacak o yüzden size ilk
paylaşmak istediğim mesaj Şu arkadaşlar
hızlanmak için yavaşlayın
ikinci Hikayem şurada
şimdi
hepimiz
[Müzik]
Bendeki Duygu neydi biliyor musunuz ha
daha hala bir şeyler yapabilirim mutlu
muydum değildim ama hala diyordum ki ben
o zirveye çıkarsam İnşallah mutlu
olacağım
ne oldu biliyor musunuz Bir gün uyandım
şu iki parmağım uyuşmuş
Neyse doktora gittim babamın tanıdığı
lise arkadaşı Osman amca diye birisi
şöyle MR'a baktı Oğlum dedi Sen
reklamcısın senin anlayacağın dilden
anlatayım başına ne gelmiş Calgon
reklamlarını hatırlıyor musun dedi Evet
dedim hatırlıyorum orada dedi bir tane
Çubuk var evet dedim kireç tutmuş
rezistans o dedi Senin boyun kemiklerin
eyvah dedim ne yapacağız peki dedi ki
sen bir şey yapmayacaksın artık senlik
bir şey kalmamış bizde de şah damarını
sağa çekeceğiz nefes Borunun sola
çekeceğiz ses tellerini yukarı
kaldıracağız Ondan sonra buradan
keseceğiz içeri gireceğiz içeri
girdikten sonra
annenin tencerenin dibindeki kireçleri
kazıması gibi kireçlerini kazacağız
Ondan sonra
boyunun eğri kalmasın diye oraya platin
vidalar takacağız dedim bu kadar mı evet
dedi dedim Teşekkür ederim oradan kaçtım
diğer beyin cerrahlarına gittim baktım
hepsi Osman amcanın Bana anlattığı
konuda son derece motive hepsi aynı şeyi
yapmak istiyorlar dedim bari tanıdık
birisi yapsın ve kendimi teslim ettim
kendimi teslim ettim buradan buraya
kadar kestiler arkadaşlar Ondan sonra da
içeriye platin vidalar taktılar ben
zirveye çıkarsam orada bir şey
Bulacağımı zannediyordum Halbuki
arkadaşlar yol üzerinde hem sağlığımı
hem mutluluğumu pek çok şeyimi kaybettim
O yüzden çok sevdiğim bir laf var Onu
paylaşmak istiyorum sizinle
everest'in tepesinde bulacağın huzur
oraya götürdüğün huzurdur o duruma
gideyim kafe açayım oraya gideyim o
zaman mutlu olurum Bunu yaparsam O zaman
mutlu olurum Bunu yaparsam o zaman
huzurlu olurum Maalesef öyle değil ben
bunu durmayı doktorun sayesinde birazcık
öğrendim Ondan sonra da işte
mindfulness'la tanıştım hayat devam etti
Şimdi
hepimizin hayatında arkadaşlar
hayatında şöyle bir şey var benim en
azından hayatımda mükemmelliğiyetçilik
vardı Nasıl bir şey mükemmelliyetçilik
sınavdan 9 alırsın baban der ki Neden
onu almadın mükemmelleşip böyle başlar
her zaman dersin ki her şey olduğunda
rahat edeyim tatile gidersin her şey
güzeldir dersin ki rüzgarda şöyle ise
güzel olur ya da Rüzgar esmesin İşte
buradaki kahvaltı şöyle olsa her zaman
bir takılacak bir yer vardır benim de
kafa hep böyle takılan bir kafaydı
Hala da çoğunlukla takılıyor ama
arkadaşlar benim kafamı bu konuda
değiştiren bakın başıma bir şey geldi
şimdi benim kardeşim Bir gün dedi ki abi
dedi Ben evleniyorum Tabi bunu nereden
söylüyor biliyor musun tokyo'dan çocuk
japonya'daydı Japon bir kızla tanışmış
aşık olmuş evleniyor iyi dedik düğün
Japonya'da olacak Biz de atladık
Japonya'ya gittik Japonya'da düğünü
yaptıktan sonra Arkadaşlar ben kendime
böyle bir hafta on gün izin verdim
Japonya'yı göreyim gezeyim diye
Ondan sonra
Japonya'da kyoto'da böyle gezerken
Oranın çok meşhur bir tapınağının bir
bahçesine denk geldim şu gördüğünüz
bahçe tam olarak orası buranın adı
royalji Tapınağı Bu da bir Zen bahçesi
bahçe dediğime bakmayın bitki yok bakın
sadece taş var neyse ben bu bahçenin
burada bu insanlar gibi şöyle durdum
Baktım bahçeye orada bir tane görevli
var
görevliye dedim ki burada dedim ne
oluyor bak bakalım dedi bahçede dedi kaç
tane taş var dedi şöyle bir baktım
Saydım dedim 14 tane dedik Emin misin
böyle deyince dedim ki bir saniye
bakayım şöyle bahçenin etrafında
dolanmaya başladım dolanmaya başlayınca
gördüm ki bahçenin taşlarını öyle bir
dizmişler ki bakın şöyle göstereyim bazı
taşlar diğerlerinin arkasında kalıyor
yani baktığın yerden her taşı
göremiyorsun yani etrafında dolaşınca
arkadaşlar taşları Saydım dedim ki 15
tane evet dedi 15 tane var evet
Peki dedi sen dedi 15'ini görebildiğin
bir nokta var mı Hepsini aynı anda bu
sefer ben iyice o kafayla hepsini
göreceğim hepsini göreceğim 15'in birini
de göreceğim diye dört dönmeye başladım
arkadaşlar 3-4 tur döndükten sonra
görevli yanıma geldi dedi ki dur
baktım
görebildim mi dedi yok dedim dur dedi
durdum otur dedi oturdum 15 yi görmeyi
çalışmayı bırak dedi
Ne yapayım dedim bahçeye bak dedi
baktım
bakış o bakış O kadar hoşuma bir şeyi
olmayan göremediğim bir şeyi orada eksik
olan bir şeyi aramaya çalışmayı
bırakınca
orada olan şeyin güzelliğini gördüm
buradaki kayaları öyle bir yapmışlar ki
okyanusun üzerinde Adalar gibi oranın
kokusu Şuradaki Kiraz ağaçlarını görüyor
musunuz inanılmaz bir kokusu var çok
böyle su sesleri içerisinde çok huzurlu
bayıldım
dedim ki burada ne oluyor
görevli dedi ki
Japonya'da 15 sayısı
mükemmeliyetçiliği ifade eder mükemmeli
ifade eder Ve dedi Burası dedi hayatı
sembolize eden bir bahçe dedi
bizim hayatımızda gençken enerjimiz
vardır tecrübemiz yoktur tecrübemiz
olduğunda
zamanımız olmaz zamanımız olduğunda
hayatımızda yanımızda belki
sevdiklerimiz olmaz sevdiklerimiz Olur
enerjimiz olur zamanımız olur sağlığımız
olmaz yani bir şeyi varken
bir şeyde olmaz
Hayat tam olarak böyle olduğu için
burada 15 taş var ama biz nereden
bakarsak bakalım en fazla 14'ünü
görebiliyoruz
ve
ne zaman ki
15 taşı da o eksik göremediğini de
görmeyi o çabayı bırakıp da o sırada ne
görebiliyorsan onun keyfine varmaya
baktığında o zaman hayattan yani
Bahçeden keyif alabiliyorsun
Ben anladım ki orada
aramayı bıraktığımız zaman tam olarak
bulduğumuz zaman
Benim bugün buraya gelmemin ve size
aktarmak istediğim arkadaşlar mesaj Şu
belki durmak deyince hepinizin aklına
şöyle durmak geliyor olabilir Ama ben
şöyle bir gözünüzü kapayıp şunu
canlandırmanızı istiyorum Acaba Senin
durum ne
oturmak mı Belki senin durun oturmak
Belki senin durun köpek gezdirmek Belki
senin durumun Yoka yapmak Belki senin
durum mercimek köftesi yapmak Eğer ki
senin durum koşmak herkesin
durup farklı olabilir evet
Ama ortak olan şey şurası
hayatımızda Eğer
durursak bunun şekli şemalinin çok da
önemli değil durursak ve bakarsak
hayatımızın da şekli şemalinin çok
önemli değil Hangi açıdan baktığımızın
da çok önemli diye durur ve bakarsak o
zaman hayatımızda illaki yaşamaya değer
keyif almaya değer
kucaklamaya değer sevmeye değer öpmeye
değer sarılmaya değer bir şeyler illaki
göreceğiz
buradan ayrılırken şunu söylemek
istiyorum
durmaktan korkmayın Haydi bir durun
Çünkü hayat Durdukça
[Alkış]